salut brut c'est kung et je vais vous
parler des cinq artistes qui m'ont
influencé
[Musique]
indochine c'était le premier groupe que
j'ai vu en live de toute ma vie c'est
mon père qui m'avait amené au zénith de
toulon et moi qui à l'époque essayez un
peu de faire de la guitare et essayer de
monter mon groupe de rock avec des potes
ça avait été vraiment un moment
incroyable et c'est là que je me suis
vraiment rendu compte que c'est ce que
je voulais faire faire de la musique et
faire et faire danser les gens
[Musique]
le deuxième groupe qui m'a influencé
c'est un groupe anglais qui s'appelle
the kooks
c'est
vraiment pour moi une époque au collège
où j'écoutais que ça et j'ai énormément
de souvenirs sur leur musique
j'ai un morceau en tête particulièrement
qui s'appelle seaside qui était un
morceau de gros romantique que j'ai
envoyée à toutes les filles que je
voulais travailler à l'époque et et j'ai
eu la chance à près de 2 de faire un
morceau avec luke pritchard qui est le
chanteur du groupe et de le rencontrer
de pouvoir être en studio avec lui à
londres c'était un moment incroyable
troisième influence c'est un duo qui
s'appelle les bloody beetroots ça a été
ma première claque électro j'arrivais à
des soirées organisées par mes potes
avec une paire d'enceintes prêté par ma
soeur à l'époque et je faisais genre le
dj en levant toutes les musiques des
bloody beetroots il ya un morceau en
particulier s'est dit mac mini kai chen
qui m'a vraiment pété le cerveau et
c'est à partir de ce moment là où je me
suis dit que je voulais essayer des dj
donc j'ai demandé j'ai demandé un
contrôleur des espèces de petites
platine à mes potes pour mon
anniversaire et je n'arrêtais pas de
regarder des vidéos 2d bloody beetroots
à tomorrowland
la quatrième inspiration c'est martin
solveig que j'écoute depuis très
longtemps maintenant qui a toujours été
un des dj préféré je trouve qu'il a
vraiment un truc différent et et c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui m'a inspiré
depuis très longtemps et j'ai eu la
chance de travailler avec lui maintenant
depuis quelques années et notamment sur
mes deux derniers morceaux qui s'appelle
never going rogue et lipstick
son titre in toxiques eighties m'a
vachement inspiré pour faire it girl
pour faire cesser ces notes de trompette
je me suis vachement inspiré de son son
drop sur in toxiques est utile
j'ai pas si je vais déjà dit donc voilà
martin je te l'avouer aujourd'hui merci
j'ai toujours été un très très très
grand fan de florence and the machine
c'est pour moi une des meilleures
performeuses qui existe sur scène je
n'ai jamais eu jamais eu la chance de la
voir en live en vrai mais j'ai maté
beaucoup de vidéos et avec les daft punk
par exemple c'est un mets de mes
concerts de rêve j'aimerais vraiment la
voir en live un jour et ouais c c c c c
est une des chanteuses avec la plus
belle voix qui existe à la une prestance
à la une classe incroyable
[Musique]